hello everyone the Tata Steel chess
tournament is over Magnus Carlsen wrap
that up very nicely it's time to shift
our attention to the Gibraltar trade
wise chess festival here we have a very
nice game between Vasilyev Antioch and
Israeli grandmaster Talbot on the game
is from round five and before I forget
there is a link in the description below
where you can watch an interview with
vastly von Schuch by tanya Satya after
this game so let's see this interesting
game eventual opens the game with d4
well Knight to f6 c4 g6 the Kings Indian
defense g3 and c5 Knight to f3 Bishop to
g7 Bishop to g2 and now see captures on
d4 Knight chapters on d4 by von Schuch
butter on castles and we have a night to
see - seems like it's wasting a temple
but this night will be very useful on c2
as it will not be a target for this
bishop after this Knight moves and also
it's it's really an enforcing that d4
square so Knight to c6
we have Knight to c3 g6 and Bishop to d2
rook to b8 again I useful move getting
the work out of da it's where as this
bishop will in some variations later be
able to to harass the Repsol a very
useful move maybe preparing a 6 b5 in
some variations b3 by Yvonne Chaka Queen
d7 and rook to c1 b6 now the castles and
Bishop to b7 e 4 by bunch of a6 and
queen to e2 now you can see that the
queen is nicely placed the rooks are now
connected and all of the land rooks
pieces are are almost ideally placed the
time to time to think of a plan now rook
F to c8 and we have rook F to D one
Bishop to a8 and we have h3 not allowing
this Knight any Knight to g4 ideas and
so it's always a useful move maybe in
the future we will you will go King to
h2 maybe improve the position of your
king
go f4 and create some sort of a King
side attack and here we had a night to a
seven as you'll see in the interview
with vastly one took after this game
this night to a seven eventually
describes it as a weird move nights the
before now you can see that this night
comes to be for would have temple on the
a6 pawn a5 defending and kicking the
night away and Knight to d5 and what do
you do here is black here Baron played
rook to e8 one my thinkers and white
controls more space maybe I want to
trade it down but here's what happens if
you decide to trade on for example
Knight captures he captures and now for
example e six pawn captures Queen
captures and since white does control
more space he probably doesn't want to
exchange Queens so let's say Bishop to
e3 and now black can exchange a lot of
pieces for example Bishop captures King
captures Bishop captures rook captures
and let's say rook to e8 okay you did
trade down some pieces but if you look
at the position White has two point
islands blackest three point islands so
White's pawn structure is definitely
better and White has a very active
Bishop against this well knight on a 7
and it doesn't matter even if the knight
improves its position the dark squares
around the King are very weak so white
would definitely have plenty of
advantage in this game so Baron doesn't
go for something like this he plays rook
to e8 we had Bishop to e3 now with a
double attack on the b6 pawn Queen to d8
defending the pawn and here in this
position it took vastly bunch of 22
minutes to play his next move and he
played f4 we have Knight to d7 and
Bishop to F to push up the c6 now and
team to h2 like I said always a useful
move Knight the c5 now and d5 we have D
captures on e5 f captures on e5 and
Bishop back to a8 and here eventually
has a couple of options how to how to
continue this game he decides to go for
the most active one he plays d6
and here there are a lot of threats as
you can see this Bishop R is very strong
here it's if black ever captures then
you want to capture some bishop with
bishop on d5 and this this will be a
very strong piece so what do you play
here here if you play something like f
captures on e6 you get the knight to f6
check this opens up an attack from the
roof to your queen and after Knight is
captured simply rope captures and after
it captures you can exchange a couple of
more pieces and after something like
night to b5 is like it does have a rook
and Knight and the pawn for the Queen
but it's it's it's much much better
position for white not likely that black
can hold this so after each six Baron
played Bishop captures on d5 rook
captures on d5 attacking the Queen and
here we have Queen to c7 and this allows
eventual to finish the game in great
style it's a very nice move feel free to
pause the position it's not a very hard
move it's really very I mean it's very
how would I say it I have no idea what's
the word I'm looking for
it's very intuitive so here a man who
played Bishop characters on c5 first B
captures on c5 and here rope to d7 and
did this room to d7 was the idea that's
why I had to capture the knight on c5
and it was in this position after up to
d7 that table are on I designed the game
what if you resign well first of all
your queen is attacked and if you move
the Queen your knight is attacked on a
seven so let's say you try to defend
this Queen to b6 you instantly get each
captures on f7 with check if you move
the King of course pawn captures rook
you lose a whole rook and if you catch
red you get Bishop to d5 check King has
to move and now rook to f1 and here the
King has no more squares Bishop f6
blocking and now the simple Knight to e4
is quite sufficient to win the game
immediately
black doesn't really have a move here
you can try something like
the g7 unpinning but now simply rook
captures and it's a game over the rook
is protected so the King can't capture
it you can't capture with the pawns
since the point is spin from the rock on
d7 only other thing you can do is maybe
capture it with the Queen but after
Queen captures Knight captures King
captures Queen e6 and here is simply
capture capture capture and when the
King moves you can either play g4 and go
for checkmate or simply grab the night
and it's an easily winning game another
thing after up to these seven if you
play any other move you lose the knight
on a seven but why doesn't even have to
go for that for example Queen to e5 you
can still use the same idea simply he
captures on f7 this is what check you
have to capture King captures now again
bishop d5 King to f8 and again rook to
f1 and after Bishop blocks you seem to
play Queen captures on e5 because now
the bishop is pinned so you lose the
Queen and the game so a very nice game
from round five of the Gibraltar trade
wise chess festival by Vasily line check
against all boron like I said to check
out the interview with a bunch of there
is a link in the description below
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and I've seen again from round six by
vastly von Schuch and that game
eventually definitely didn't enjoy but I
will show you that game as well
unfortunately not today today I had a
very busy day so only one video for
today but tomorrow everything goes back
to normal and in addition to two videos
per day I will do I will do a short test
stream on Twitch tomorrow morning so all
of you who can join do join I will not
create a tournament or anything I will
just since I've never used to which I
just want to see if everything will be
working fine so I will be accepting some
challenges feel free to challenge me and
you know just some light Q&A you can ask
anything you want about chess about
youtube about the world the universe you
know any anything anything goes so yeah
that's it I would like to thank at enira
and Sunday
grande dick for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon